[Music]
in young hacker news submitted by hacked
by Peter Oh Peter Peter a 16 year old
pled guilty to hacking apple's mainframe
oh [ __ ] 16 baller that's really cool
these guys are geniuses no I would have
hired him yeah you should yeah that's
the reason why he was hacking because
we're close to work or Apple but then he
got in trouble
man of the company I'm just kidding oz
what he wants what a badass video at
home
you better unless Bill Gates hires us
like a sausage sighs yeah yeah so this
dude he he hacked into apples mainframe
he downloaded internal files and he
access customer accounts Wow but Apple
swears that it didn't affect anything Oh
like everyone's information was safe but
their report is a white hat hacker what
is that he's just the one that goes in
and says hey your systems vulnerable but
I am doing nothing malicious yeah yeah
so then this dude this kid bio he's from
Melbourne Australia he studies in a
private school and he they're also
reporting that he's stored the saved
information to a folder called hacky
heck heck his porn father the most
juvenile being to synchronize to copy
the private they weren't of the same sex
I think they'd be with each other yeah
if we were two girls lesbian time I
don't want to touch up good you the guy
okay I mean you could still be a soul
mate without like a sexual yeah that's I
call them soul mates yeah I see that
small mates bro-mates know there's soul
mates soul burrows we're yin and yang no
you guys are this you're yin and Yan
dude oh [ __ ] okay I don't know how that
worked but I guess I'd be accessible but
yeah so this kid he downloaded 90
gigabytes files damn that's a lot I mean
like is well there's not a picture
because he looks just like one person's
iPhone that's what I was gonna say it
like 90 gigs is not that much really not
that much a week one phone yeah yeah
well they did there are saying that he
hacked it like four times or something
but that's all he downloaded 90 gigs of
secret files damn customer files
customer files all of their emails all
of that [ __ ] no so the company is saying
that no one's like like personal data
was not compromised so I don't know
exactly what did he hack it from the
school's computer I don't know where he
acted but he just saved it at the
schools that make you how did he get
discovered wait who said school no he
goes to a private oh ok so for some
reason I mixed it to some random like
bit of information for you to know like
okay oh like you had a really good
education
you know sometimes I like to hear the
stories of hackers that basically come
from like nothing like there's this one
notorious one that I think he went and
broke through the Pentagon or some
insane [ __ ] and he's like some dude that
lives in like I'm with his mom still in
like in like the hood like in the
projects and [ __ ] ya know it's it's an
actual guy yeah but it's hidden yeah I
mean it's like Hughes he was broke all
his life like poor kid and it's like he
just learned all that [ __ ] on his own
crazy okay I liked you because you were
nothing like me
no but like a genius girl you you taught
yourself to write thank you for giving
me a little bit of credit thank you yes
with the internet I guess everybody
could learn yeah learn how to fry an egg
by myself genius damn on YouTube no I
just trying it at home I just try at
home see what happened you know what
though like there is no excuse nowadays
with with Google and everything there's
just no excuse not like if you didn't
want to learn some [ __ ] you could type
it in right now
and do it and do it well too they teach
you that untested me Street so Tycho
watch a Sesame Street now oh really
yeah and it's this little phone and then
it's like when you want to know if I
think it's a song obviously but
basically says ah the third they're
grooming the kids and it's like hey when
you want to know something what do we do
and it goes we look it up that's dope
you watch it I know but I think I just
don't okay we're old farts is because
like when I see like kids talking about
some [ __ ] they'll immediately go into
their phones and find out facts right
but old farts will sit there and debate
about something when they can look up
what the bus is all the time yeah taking
news and I'm like holy crap like why do
I do this
why don't because even older farts do
that for like one hour I feel like I
look so I think we like hearing each
other just try to figure it out
yeah and then once we've all realized we
don't know it then the moments passed I
don't give a [ __ ]
do I look stuff up all the time but you
know what it is too though it's like I
don't look up certain things cuz who
gives a [ __ ] you know what I mean
there's a lot of stuff that who gives a
[ __ ] if you know that if I need to remit
is that pretty American if it's not
conducive to the conversation or the
mood that's going on who gives a [ __ ]
cuz sometimes a lot of people say stuff
that's not true but they believe it you
know but it doesn't hurt you or me in
that in that whatever misinformation
that you have so you just let that
person talk and the conversation goes on
you don't have to stop somebody to a by
the way you're wrong yeah one it
embarrasses a person and number two it
doesn't matter if they know or not yeah
so people don't have that [ __ ] social
conscience I see it all the time now
where they literally stop a conversation
to correct somebody on some information
that nobody gives a [ __ ] about right
yeah exactly that's a great point yeah I
hate you so but that's a great point
that's exactly what that's like getting
an ego fix out of something that you
don't like it's like such an insecure
yeah like somebody uses a title of their
in there and they go by the way yeah we
know that it's a typo you dumb [ __ ] move
on [ __ ] loser
so you've been corrected a lot for this
is just you lashing I just roll them
back and when they write the correct
there then you write the wrong one with
the [ __ ] asterisk on purpose because
here's the thing though because I'm
naturally in it is do we like just just
losers that do that actually it's like
not even Poindexter's it's like next
week you might not even be smart and you
still do that I don't because I correct
term is I like people who are just like
somewhat socially aware you know I mean
like just know the mood know what's
going on yeah I mean so if you're not
doing that just go into a [ __ ] corner
and be by yourself I felt like that's
that's the thing I just hate there yeah
that's true but sometimes I just have a
thought and I know that it means [ __ ]
nothing but I am obsessive about where
barley came from that's different
first of all the seas are two separate
conferences
no genuine like he really wants to know
did you figure it out I forgot that's
why it's over I need a [ __ ] dog did
it come from [ __ ] like rain isn't it
what's the part of Mesopotamia Sumeria I
think so I mean that's one of the first
places that you know had farming and
shin you know so it might be you know
there's there's ancient grains and [ __ ]
like that I was like damn man I didn't
know that we cross bread so many [ __ ]
grains that this is rice or this is what
it is today you know you go through that
rabbit hole [ __ ] Wikipedia where you
see like sort of banana look like
looking up like what fruits were before
the genetic or lemons and limes like
what they were before oh yeah can old
watermelon dude [ __ ] that dismal yeah it
was like 12% of the fruit and the rest
of it looks like all rind and then a
little bit of peace with it [ __ ] tons
of seeds looks like that's something you
eat and then how did they genetically
like figure out to genetically modify it
to like make learning yeah they do they
see fruits they smell it yeah they crack
it open see what's up these the best one
years and years of just like people
dying really just animals eat something
and in just copying them that's that's
enough they die though but those that
believe in evolution we've learned these
things from like when we were like Apes
we learned certain things and then that
was just ingrained and we learned more
and more I mean and now we got Wikipedia
[ __ ] that now I could go into the forest
and I could just be like is this
mushroom cool take a picture it they're
like don't eat it dude okay cool
so random do not read it yeah don't you
like [ __ ] nature expert 55 or some
[ __ ] like that you know so bad for that
dude in a into the wild at the end of
the film ass so it'd still be just
forever forever his fault ever
it is forever Jack Jack Jack Jack the
little kid and the guy it's the guy who
was like oh no oh yeah this is the one
that you said you haven't seen oh into
the wall he lives on a bus or something
found yeah so great that kid is such a
good actor into the wall I just saw it
like a couple months ago probably one of
the better films I've ever seen in my
life
made me so sad when he was dying in that
bus and he found out the meaning of life
is like an early college or something
came along read it in school
I think everyone read it at school you
should watch it it's on Netflix it's
actually a really good film it may be
tear up so what's the meaning Allah make
me tear up
it doesn't make you tear because you're
sad it makes you tear up because you're
beautiful them can connect to it very
well so what's the meaning of life it's
a it's not about experiencing all these
things by yourself it's about
experiencing things is sharing what
people baffle needed to died at [ __ ]
not told you that [ __ ] earlier
dumbass
the point of living if you don't have
people that you don't love it's like all
these people that are like oh I don't
know why they always go to India and
[ __ ] but like everyone said to find
myself and write a [ __ ] motorcycle
scooter and share like whatever bike
around India I would go to India to find
myself by myself and then they come back
and they're like oh you know what I
don't know and then they're like I miss
my friends I just like gone [ __ ]
I just picture this [ __ ] like hipster
white dude with dreadlocks he went to
India for ten years to find himself he
comes and meets you and he goes I found
the meaning to life and you know that's
one of the biggest things that people
say like toward the end of life is like
my my regret is I work too much I didn't
spend enough time exactly the elbe
balance man it's like people man work
ISM then just balance everything out
like even people are like super
aggressively every day you got a bubble
my [ __ ] back to 20 years around you're
gonna hate your life like like you said
that he works I forgot the number of
like a crazy amount of that's I think
that's what I'm passionate I think
people that work just to get success and
money and yes that is you know every
other area of your life is lacking and I
you know those types of people you see
those sets of people it's like later on
you're screaming miserable or you're
probably miserable now and you just are
masking it with more success and more
let me get this so I can validate myself
it's like you're not really truly yeah
happy it's like there should be a
balance all about it's like this should
be just as important as this isn't part
of this and every element should be
equal in parts I think
[Music]